SPEAKER: Hello, and welcome to this introductory demo to the network
simulation tool Cisco Packet Tracer.
Looking down here at the devices and components
you can take into to the workspace.
And down here is a submenu of those.
You can click through, and the name appears there.
And these are the devices themselves.
And you can see the name appearing as the mouse hovers over each one.
So let's take a few out into the workspace by clicking and dragging.
We've got things like an air conditioner unit, fire sprinkler,
or network-capable devices in this instance.
And looking across here in devices, that's
looking at computers, TVs, phones, and tablets.
Going across here, we have other devices through here, as you can see.
Let's just take a smoke detector.
If we're looking in here, we've got microcontroller board, single board
computers.
We've got alarms and LEDs.
All can be simulated to be used in Packet Tracer.
And our Sensors category, we've got humidity sensors,
switches, temperature sensors, lots of other options.
Going back here, we have our actual network devices,
such as routers and switches, cell towers
to connect mobile devices to the network, and home gateways.
So just say I'm in a menu and I've put something out that I didn't want,
I can either undo it or redo.
Or use this button over here, we'll delete And we switch back, like that.
Now, we also click on the device to view the specifications.
We can see the physical or the configuration settings.
You can view a web browser on devices like a computer,
change the configuration.
All the settings are available by clicking on the device, such as this.
And just say you were looking to find out the range of outputs,
you can see this is analog represented as 0 to 255,
which is equivalent of 0% to 100%.
So 255 is equal to, "100% humidity," for example.
OK, we have to look at how to actually network
and connect these things together by configuring them and connecting them
with cables in a future demonstration.
But for now, that's just a brief introduction.
And you can look around and explore for yourself.